hello welcome to a new video you like
the cubit thing video yesterday and I
just spontaneously decided to have a
look at the currently running games
again here on icc so at some five-minute
game here and i really prefer these two
to the three minute games to two do
comentarii upon it's just a little bit
more time to to look at the stuff and
also yeah there's simply less some yeah
big mistakes in though so who's playing
here this is on the white side
international master hit some endless
dark this is conrad hold it's a pretty
young american player 19 years old I
think I may be at best 20 i think is 19
and he will become a grandmaster in
about one or two month and he is a super
strong blitz player you see his rating
as 2600 something in the five-minute
form and he's really really strong and
blitz I think I have one of the worst
possible scores against him I think I
have like nothing maybe a draw here and
there but I don't really remember that I
even won a game and this is this rarely
happens yeah at least win once in a
while ok so I'm black player some grand
master from Cuba let me check this
quickly no arista god oh yellow 2600
something ok 26 10 ok so we've got a
pretty high rated to duel him I'm Holt
has got about 2500 something um and over
the bottom tournament chess ok so we got
an Enzo this case came came from an Enzo
Indian and we've got pretty typical kind
of game for the NIMS Oh Black has some
given our BOCES bishops but has a very
healthy pawn structure and white suffers
a bit from those weaknesses here on c4
especially a 3 also bit weak but not not
the current
target the question is some yellow black
be able to get something on those
weaknesses only question is some can
white equalized in this position yeah y
term might have ideas to bring an ID
yeah I expected this a night to live on
e4 see 3d 5 or something along these
lines and Knight to g5 492 b5 would be
nice and it's not quite so clear how
black should strengthen his position a
problem is that he just played King f7
which maybe wasn't am was an unlucky
move because 94 Queen moves and c5 was a
check so he retreated the king and now
White has gained something the snide
only form but still not apparent erm
what white should do here Knight c3 yeah
you have to reckon with the possible
loss of the c-4 porn
maybe queen bee one something like this
yeah yeah a check it keeps you for
protected the night is not bad there of
course and if black would take on d1
rook to e1 Roxy 5 got 96 okay yeah maybe
white maybe white can play c5 at some
point and open the position this would
help him yeah get exactly and get rid of
this pawn on d5 you might have 96 they
are 96 maybe yeah black also suffers a
bit um from a slightly weakened King
position this configuration here h6 f6
and so can be a bit tricky and now you
see the night might come to e6 yeah
queen bee three or something to to get
night to e6 with check yeah Black has
been outplayed here a bit I think it's
not it's not terrible yet
it's not terrible yet I think hard to
tell i mean those guys know what they're
doing especially the white player have
much very very high respect I really I
lose like every blitz game and and this
doesn't even happen against I mean I
have a terrible school I mean I even win
occasionally against guys like Sarah one
or Christensen or whatever not not like
lots of the time but i have my wins here
and then I never won against this guy I
think okay so this a 4 porn is maybe
another source of tech here or Target
not a sauce yes I think white tries to
strengthen his position a bit and sort
of says to black okay have a good
position what are you doing black cannot
do much here 96 you could just take a
form black more or less some can only
sit in weight and the a4 porn really I
might be gone at some point Roxy for
something like this I know there's no
threat Roxy three maybe rooks III with
the idea to take on a 4 with a night
yeah this is also i'm a good move takes
away those d5 and f five squares
and this interesting black might take f2
now I'm surprised that he allowed this I
mean it's not not just a pawn it's a the
possibilities of maybe I'm giving some
check on f4 oky played 93 so this is
covered yeah Queenie 8c edge you can
play but d3 also hanging
yeah quenya so wyd now could I think
draw with night o Queen f5 check
oky tries to win he's got da porn after
all so this is certainly not dumb
unjustified like asses chances the
problem is the week in position like
always has those night f2 near 93 the
night queen of course Queen here and
you've got all these checks on the dark
squares a wide really tries hard to win
maybe it's it's not a big deal to to
sacrifice pawns here because you have
the a porn all the time like a not
easily do something okay so wyd now not
quite sure what is trying I really don't
see a winning idea the Queen on d4
always covers a seven and you cannot use
your own Queen really
yeah I'm hard to believe that this
shouldn't end in some perpetual okay but
I'm time maybe
you know white down to eight seconds
blacks really doing a good job here can
you warn you and otherwise it's made or
loss of material still looks a lot like
a draw but oh wow l had to hard to tell
now what's happening Queen dat I should
win no shouldn't it no he doesn't okay
so wyd forfeit it on time yeah he wide
tried to try too hard to to win here
really um it was a draw all the time I
said we've got another game yeah I
actually followed hold here darn och and
now he's playing hands and eric hanson
and funny he's not playing under the
Canadian flag but under Norway so not
quite sure I think you can now set up
the flags SEO as you like your hands on
the Zerg international master from
Canada and a very strong blitz player
I'm also been known on CH s cube so
we've got them a sloth IAM wear white
played this kind of condoms got the SLOS
love with age III wide got the bishop am
and yeah usually tries to open up the
position in a slow manner while black
here yeah very quickly also obtained
some play on the queenside so I'm like
tries to get something on on white skin
yeah I actually must admit that I quite
like blacks position here here's some
attacking chances look wide realistic
here you just need to play something
along let's say rook c8 before and c3
and it really opens up on white skin and
it's not so easy to see what wide should
do g4 h4 h5 sis stuff that takes some
time so black is most certainly
wicker if you if you're playing for pure
race so maybe um white needs to do
something in the center okay this is an
interesting move blocking a five and
maybe trying to play a 3m to keep the
queenside close interesting black might
consider night be eight year might be a
dismay be an idea because the knight on
c6 would to win the tempo and would
support this before stuff night badm
could could be an idea or you can always
play this rook c8 like these yeah yeah
actually both Wroxham came into
consideration to be put on mercy eight I
think I would have more would have been
more inclined to use the F rook but okay
yeah now Bishop before as a threat
winning an exchange so black needs to do
something here I'm not much else to to
keep the exchange yeah very complicated
position yeah I'd still like black here
this is maybe not justified but now it's
hard to play against two bishops because
while you're very often you cannot
really exchange them stuff because this
kind of terrible endgame always looms
sir and yeah you need to be very
cautious and simplifying the position
okay so white wine form play in the
center like yeah black couldn't really
am allowed um couldn't really allow on
that white place 52 also concrete thread
yeah so now black has some play in the
center very nice Queen only five and ya
still the bishop am is a problem
yeah black doesn't want to exchange
Queens this is understandable he could
only exchange Queens if you would have a
very concrete compensation for the
bishop air let's say with queens are off
then maybe he would have he needs to be
able to play stuff like 97 to e5 to d3
so to sort of set up an internal night
there on d3 some of this would be some
compensation ok so what so what's
happening now wyd um yeah I thought what
would maybe who need to protect us maybe
I can even take her take g2 I didn't you
didn't do so okay it makes sense of
course he tries to use this weekend
squares on the queenside on the on the
on the kingside sorry so um might bring
a night to f form so exchange Queens
Knight f4 to d3 this's yeah comparable
to to what I mentioned not why I g75 t3
but we are aged 52 2 d 3 yeah now that
could take on you one and play Knight f4
can t while this really in a really
surprising move I'm sorry looks very
weakening but ok it activates the rock
on the 8th and smear
Oh night be three now maybe would would
have been interesting yeah now it gets
very very tactical yeah I'm night queen
to f4 you don't have have much else here
Queen f2 maybe but wyd also has got
Queen 35 mm mm mm 25 year most likely
hear back has always Queen f7 to protect
us yeah this is how to how to do
commentary upon pure pure tactics
five power of god we've got material
equality and it's just a matter of peas
activity we all night f form and the
question is what is the rook doing now
you two also is hanging so maybe white
needs to take on g7 with the rookie on
rookie g7 queen g7 Queen F form yeah
black might be good here but it's so
still tough only imagine that the bishop
would come to see three no no why why
can you yeah you can just take you to we
all care so black is winning no it's
just an extra piece and why just trying
to muddy the water so you can take the
66 knowing okay maybe this one as well
yeah h1 hanging and there's nothing yeah
wyd really a broke down quickly here
black also played very very very fast
also and there was super surprised about
f5 really and he played this rather
quickly I think yeah it's not it's not
entirely pointless of course you you
really activate your pieces and why does
a bit clumsy at the moment with his son
bishops they're very nice long term but
they're not doing much at the moment and
those nights are possibly coming to f4
d3 are always some steering up trouble
here so I'm very interesting i think
that black also could have played slower
like taking night f form wouldn't be bad
also but he really sharpened the
position yet and he had quite some
sometime advantage also this sir this
certainly helped and um
think in this position yeah white need
to to take on on g7 can actually use
those son oh yeah I'm learning on the
fly here can I actually use so the yeah
i can now i can use the arrows so what
may be needed to take here okay so we've
got a new game here of the same player
hold again oops somewhat screwed up here
okay so an Enzo animas Oh again yeah he
played played this before in a game
which I didn't didn't do comments upon
on this btx III which is kind of
uncommon after you played Quincy to
which usually Telsa like okay I will
recapture with the Queen so this sort of
transposase into him yeah formation that
is more common in the Rubenstein line
with with 43 so III at this point okay
like I'm recaptured on d5 with the Queen
and will most likely continue b6 here
v6b should be seven something like this
okay this is the other principal
principal DM may be playing for e five
yeah why its long-term plan here is to
if possible advanced eform be 45 her and
the other plan is exactly this c4 Bishop
b2 and trying to push d5 so I'm activate
the bishop on the long diagonal uh-huh
yeah Bishop d3 looks so normal here and
then blacks Queen needs to go to h5 aha
ok so he immediately tries to use this
this configuration here if the night
takes on d5 now white can take h7 and
might even continue with Bishop to f5
later so night XD 5 yeah it takes on h7
and Bishop f5 yeah Queen Queen 2g to h5
the only move unless sound that's some
some weird trick he ever don't think so
so Queen to h5 yeah and yeah yeah it is
playing this quicker than our the g4 mg4
comes into consideration I'm only asking
myself what happens after Queen to h3
here nergy 5 is this is the symbol 95
p.m. no just green age 6 i'm not quite
getting g4 Queen age three
what happened after what happens after
Queen age three I mean black doesn't
have any other move anyway I think Queen
age six is just just weird and now Queen
to h4 yeah what rf4 cool i'm sorry i'm
not quite sure if this is so great for
white i mean you also weakened um your
King position quite considerably here
one idea of course is rook f3 to h3 this
rook lift and of course this would
somewhat highlight blacks precarious
Queen position okay so black wants to
play actively himself this is
interesting if white would take with the
rook LG 5 is hanging and now it's got 94
yeah this is interesting cool
continuation by black here non-latex f5
and now maybe just Quinn g4 and takes on
f5 yeah this is very interesting
especially for blitz game because no
nadja for a queen g4 i don't think there
should be anything else yeah Quinn g3
and takes now and now black has got two
ponds for his piece and he's got this
long diagonal it's not so clear all this
ninth Queen on f5 also protects h7 so
why cannot go okay wyd exchange screens
would make sense if min it's a bit scary
the skin position but now you have you
have a quite strange night on h3 and
maybe black can just play normal moves
and try to even play for compensation
here in the end game it's not easy at
all for white to to to play this Black
has also ideas like King h7 g6 f5
activating the king white white has a
very stupid night on age three and the
bishop won't be too which isn't
attacking anything it's just these are
two pretty much dead pieces at the
moment you need to really am sort of
activate them but one thing I didn't
really pay attention to have to know
it's the clocks white was so much
quicker he's got more than three and a
half minutes left while black gets down
to 48 seconds yeah it's a looks a bit
like like he came played by me as black
that's maybe not one hundred percent
correct but interesting and maybe you
could play it but you're just slow yeah
maybe Luke h8 m2 to attack to take the
h2porn
yeah this is I'm not sure about you
don't want to exchange so much still
still it some may be playable oh you
shouldn't have given away the a poem
okay from from a pure okay this was a
rook yeah black gum like simply it was
killed you too here's some his time
deficit he just spent far too too much
time here I mean it's not like I'm the
guy who can can preach this I'm playing
to slow myself um but this was a very
interesting way to to continue here
interesting interesting game I think
black really has some decent
compensation it's not like a crazy p
sacrifice which which doesn't work or
something it's quite quite interesting
okay so I'm not quite sure if I should
still follow the white player here he
because there are some other games going
on at the moment which I'm also
interesting maybe but maybe have
progressed already to a certain oh no we
could we could do this year yeah let's
do this Turkish star against here arrows
Hansen again I'm not quite sure who's
Turkish star or whatever Ricardo and
Radek charisma Bernardo okay oh no idea
who this guy is his doesn't have a flag
in there ok so I'm but she's super high
oh you've got da knock again so let's
let's let's stay here I mean no don't
want to switch games all the time and
some different players also not bad so
I'm then the opening its nine and I go
quickly to the first moves we efforts
have closed Sicilian here where black
played the funny movie 65
very often you can lose the temple like
this if white um has played played the
knight on f3 because in this close
structure you sort of prefer to use the
F pawn and this is also our white is
regrouping here yeah black has this
typical botvinnik set up house so it's
called with c5 and d5 which really
clamps down on the default point so I'm
like has a good control here and this
only problem is some the d5 square what
white is now doing really surprises me
spend some quite some time to exchange
the c8 bishop which of course Nets wide
the bishop pair but I mean the position
is fairly closed and it certainly takes
a while to to open it up also surprised
that black takes so much time here so
it's really a an important point here
interesting yeah i think the p5 Knight
b6 what the idea of interesting yeah
maybe this is a good regrouping so we've
got a maneuvering game here black
prevented any default kinds of ideas
with a setup from white and it's a
matter of porn porn levers here black
hand attack on the queenside what she is
what is doing also fif is a general idea
for wide it's a form but you need to be
cautious as it always opens up the
diagonals of those at the moment closed
up bishop so if black plays f-5e takes
f5 would open up the bishop and this is
also why have five wasn't playable at
all and f4 from wide also it's quite
kind of weakening so why pushed the H
pawn and like jettison tis a porn with a
three
to weaken the greenside further yeah why
does a pawn up but it's not a great porn
so whites-only won't win with with is
extra porn here yeah black [ __ ] I think
would be happy to get rid of all night
cm so he doesn't have to reckon with a
knight coming to g5 all the time so I'm
yam again exactly f6 and now black him
it has get ridden got rid of all the
other nights here the issue here though
is the really poor bishop on h8 which
has no square and I'm not quite sure how
black should try to activate this piece
you would need to play f5 at some point
to play Bishop f6 and so on but f5 is of
course the move that pretty much chance
the g-tube bishop into a monster so this
is a tricky position yeah it looks like
black tries to maneuver a bit okay place
a 5 yeah maybe it's not it's unavoidable
in the long run but it's certainly quite
quite a risky move to open up the bishop
maybe even Bishop c6 here it's not so
easy to see how I'm black should Kavis
recover b5 yeah okay white white place
the place in normal-looking move Bishop
see success looks a bit shaky maybe it
is great maybe it is complete nonsense
so be sure roop to be three service it's
a good strengthening moves though from
yeah i'm preparing exactly this to put
my pressure on b5 yeah so maybe white
will will take now just don't be five
now you can take on be 500 exchange be
54 c 3 not sure if this is so great for
wide i mean so maybe there's some
alternative okay but he grabbed it yeah
11 issue here is like skin position he's
got a very open King why doesn't have
pieces yet yeah near blacks king but
this might might have my change soon so
maybe I'm like needs to get something
quickly III year maybe yeah he got rid
of this pawn which is understandable as
always potential threat or threats
connected to this pawn yeah now black
has got some some play against f2 this
looks okay now
black might go queen f6r queen be six or
III III will plunder the bishop not so
great but maybe we have six now know how
to calculate Queen f6 attacking f2 once
more but rook c7 there might be
something you need to calculate
Lucas assume I Roxy 7 you can also just
um take with the Queen if everything
else fails
yeah white is under some pressure here
and yeah he's running out of time not so
sure what you should play yeah Bishop f2
now maybe you can go Bishop f2 and then
rook c8 getting rid of one rook trying
to get into some yeah maybe get get get
the heavy pieces off and trying to draw
the end game against the opposite
colored with the opposite colored
bishops Queen h6e oh you can you can go
Bishop to h3 hmm
you know at best what what white can can
do it as a draw of course but you might
get this so we've gotten into this end
game at some
or was this still a draw hard to believe
maybe it is depends on on on the the
exact piece set up here i have ever game
running in the background sorry for the
take-back noise in the meantime it it
actually yeah it is a draw we've got the
open the wrong colored bishop here and
so it's it's a dead wrong yeah cool
fighting game with the ups and downs so
I think in the meantime here down lock
hold started another game this was the
state take back sound and we got some
sort of Kings Indian exchange here with
h3 though this kind of line which are
sometimes played also looked you one is
a bit uncommon here but I'm sorry
usually white um on plates long castles
here rook t1 is a similar idea of course
and i take c fire officer simple threat
and now wide can go all night d 5 which
is answered by c6 this is the idea of
black some setup i'm not quite sure
who's the black players he's got an
american flag here william stewart name
doesn't ring a bell but he's quite high
rated T on the five-minute bosom
okay so white gave this check and then
retreated to e3 this is all pretty
standard in this line Knight takes e4 he
is not possible for black because rook
no Knight xc8 and then g7 is lost so I'm
black sort of exactly needs to kick this
night to resolve this this configuration
and white now I'm not quite sure what
you're thinking about takes and place g4
is this normal g-form maybe 92 but Jeff
is the usual idea g45 yeah i'm i know
this line the bottom I prepared this
years ago for a game so yeah g-form and
now I'm yeah black needs to attend to
this threat yeah one of the one of the
ideas of this g-form move is that white
might try to play along the lines of g5
h4 Bishop h3 this f1 bishop is of course
a cause of concern for white it's quite
a bad piece and you need to get rid of
this piece and this is one way to do
this on the 83 a square um to be honest
I quite like black here still always got
his knights nicely positioned and night
f4 also possible and i'm not sure why
its position doesn't look quite right to
me
I mean certainly a black hasn't hasn't
got any any problem see em
could even think of hmm yeah yeah this
is sort of easy way to play this wide
yeah what needs to take with the king
otherwise 93 and now this position
should be quite easy for black to play
95 maybe 95 hmm all right you can you
can go rook be eight actually and then
look f 2g eight Bishop f8 and stuff like
this I mean it's it's a pretty pretty
weird position the night on f4 is just
nicely placed and what was B 6 p-6 well
do we had move he just blundered the
exchange I think night f8 and this
wasn't necessary at all yeah and why
does just completely winning now um
because of I mean okay he's got an extra
exchange but also he's got the default
which is a main feature here of course
yeah g6 so white has some quite an easy
wait quite easy ways to improve the
position not quite sure if this is a
threat yeah better but a step out of
this this bishop on h6 if you play h
takes eight h7 takes 26 you can just
take on g6
96 rook takes h6 yam Bishop f5 very nice
Bishop and then look this F now
yeah this is pretty pretty easy
technically you get get with a route 287
also get the a7 form you can protect now
the queenside first and then sort of
take the whole Queen side maybe now not
everything but one or two points maybe
you'll get
yeah black fights the fights but would
be a surprising if white would let this
slip some arm ya know route 27 and
resins I guess what no idea what
happened to at the NTM okay I'm white
was was winning this end game pretty
easily but black on black had quite a
good position I think I mean this year
it's not it's not like black as
brilliant or what but let's say rook the
eighth year and I think it's perfectly
playable but I think maybe the CIS is
questionable Black has other moves here
can can check also on f3 and return to
deform if you're content with the draw
no not so sure not so sure I'm to tidy
up a bit here sorry for the window
jittering um yeah quite quite a number
of interesting possibilities also maybe
just be six here night f for all kinds
of stuff is interesting and this is I'm
not sure if you if you really want to
drive the King up here maybe it helps a
bit with whites coordination but if you
go some here like something like rook
the eighth I don't see what what's what
the big problem yeah i mean not don't be
six but up the edge here why the
exchanges and takes on b7 you've gotta
be eight and get to get to be to not not
quite sure like shouldn't be it
shouldn't be terrible here alright so i
think um this worked out pretty well
I actually wanted to wrap up the video
but he's just started in another game
okay I'll do this I do this and then
then finish this Cupid sing session here
I've got a classical French and it took
on d4 Bishop c5 yeah all kinds of theory
here theoretical moves like usually it
tries to play on the queenside something
like take here then be five before a
five Bishop a six so i'll pretty pretty
normal yeah of course you've got this
some not so beautiful c8 bishop but
quite often you you are able to exchange
it on a six after before a five Fisher
basics and wide um often tries to attack
on them on the King side okay so black
ice trying for something entirely
different here aha so we didn't abandon
this plan just inserted this Queen a5
move okay wide push the H porn forward
yeah now you only need to magically
transfer your queen to g7 and you have
got a nice game but it's not so easy
the some f 69 and this d 7 i'd always
covers f6 so you cannot easily go Queen
age 42 f 6 or something yeah like a Scot
quite some attacker already going so
maybe not not deadly or something but
he's opening up lines very quickly yeah
maybe take on f1 and yeah night night to
be snide be 62 c-4 would be an idea guy
tries to that we need to be cautious of
the Sun yeah this crude but may be
effective it's actually quite I was
thinking about quindi age maybe not so
bad but ok he played the very direct
continuation with f5 to to close up this
possibility but
Wow super complicated him f7 check you
can just yeah I take with the rook I'm
not sure that this really brings any
dividends maybe there was something else
as super super super complicated Bishop
a2 and it's just winning pitcher bay 2
and Quincy one here now Queen a to a
queen am a choke Quincy to check
threatened and 93 ok it's mm wide maybe
oh no we can you can go Knight c3 checky
Andrew k 3 is made now and Knight c3
also should should be winning somehow
white simply hasn't got a threat here
Bishop c3 route 83 is still a mate white
only has got to check er up do look
after you've made yeah this was a quick
quick game at the end very unclear very
unclear so I'm around need to I cannot
really go back here why mm-hmm would
like to know why cannot go back and move
this irritates me all right I wanted to
wrap up this session anyway it's already
a close to 50 minutes yeah I am I hope
you enjoyed this I think about some
pretty cool games in them and some
interesting chess to to watch um yeah
and this Conrad hold guy is really a
terrific let's player I'm not quite sure
that had him in one of my comentary
games but maybe it it happens soon I'm I
need to gain some rating may be to have
a better chance my rating suffered a bit
recently in the commentary games alright
thanks for watching and leave your
questions or comments on on youtube
thanks and talk to you soon